this is why Taylor Swift got off Spotify
right I applaud her for that she said I
don't want to go along with this idea
and you hear a lot of musicians say it
that we don't care what we get paid we
just want people to hear the music it's
easy to say after you've made it
partially a lot of the reason I think is
you know removing music from Spotify is
also about control and having control
about your art I'm a songwriter the
songs that I write are dear to me and
the message is dear to me I wouldn't
want for Charles Manson to put out a
version of waking me up
I should have control over who gets to
sing that song but the copyright law for
songwriters doesn't allow that you might
want to hear that would you would huh
Wow well I would I would do my best to
try to restrict it but I would I don't
even have the control to restrict it
because the law doesn't give me the
chance and these are pickers of archaic
laws they were archaic Laura the digital
area the Briton Rudin you know 1909 when
mechanical pianos were the musical
players of the day and in order to
control how a copy of McKenna of a
scroll of music was was compensated
somebody could copy that and they just
had to pay a nine cent royalty but when
artists started covering songs that law
transferred to them so you know I think
as technology changes as the system
changes so should the laws but I know
that to put I know this because I made a
movie called Religulous and you had to
and I had to buy music thank you as the
people who like the original imagined
and I had to I had to negotiate and buy
the music to put in the movie because I
remember I wanted superstition and
Stevie Wonder said no I like be some
Jesus so you cannot have that but crazy
Cee Lo Green Thank You CeeLo we said go
right ahead yeah so when it comes to
songwriting and publishing the one place
that songwriters do have control is when
it comes to a synchronization with a
visual context with film and TV
otherwise there is really no control and
I think that it should be more of a free
market and and more control to the
songwriter you know a painter or
sculptor gets to choose the context and
the situation in which their art is
consumed and should I want to remove my
music like Taylor Swift did from Spotify
anyone else any Joe Schmo can cover all
of Taylor's to his songs put it up on
Spotify and she has no control but if
the music industry is so shitty why
don't the musicians band together it
seems like they would have the power by
just stop putting out the product
musicians are musicians we want to be
artists we want to write we want to play
we don't want to get caught up in the
quagmire of fighting for our rights we
want we just don't want to be exploited
but sometimes you have to yeah well if
freedom in free well here I am to do
that for is me right you're doing it
right
how much do you blame the consumer I
mean I think there's a whole generation
that thinks music is supposed to be free
well I think music should be excessively
free I don't think it necessarily should
be free in terms of compensation
everybody should be paying for what they
consume it's a product like anything
it's a product like and by the way it's
a product that has more longevity than
almost any other commodity I could think
of I'm listening to songs that I bought
40 years ago and they still give me
pleasure I can't think of anything else
but somebody might dick you're willing
to pay that that gave me pleasure forty
years ago what do you have to say about
that thank you for doing what they're
doing let's give music
[Applause]